hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
so democracy seems to have survived for
another day
here in the united states uh no matter
which side you're on hopefully you're
pro-democracy one way or the other of
course we had a fun conversation with
cornell west the day before election day
but
that was more about the spirit of
democracy today we're going to be
talking about the history
of democracy you know again as i said in
the previous podcast democracy is
something we take for granted we're just
taught that it's good it's a
positive valence word that you can throw
out there
when you're talking to other people but
it's not obvious right it's not
self-evident that democracy is the best
kind of government
and certainly through history places
have been democratic and places have not
been democratic so
how did it come to be democracy and
why did it sometimes go away right how
did it both get invented and why did it
sometimes get overturned
today's guest is david stasavage who is
dean for the social sciences as well as
a professor of politics at nyu and he
has a book out on
the decline and rise of democracy where
it's a wonderful book you know very
readable
big picture history kind of book but he
makes a couple of very interesting
points that weren't obvious one is that
we think of in our western focused
viewpoint
democracy as coming to be in greece and
then spreading to rome and then kind of
fading away before being rediscovered
which is a very inaccurate history of
early democracy
in david savage's point of view he
thinks that early democracy was all over
and i shouldn't say he thinks
he points out correctly and obviously to
any historian
early democracy was all over the place
there are many
societies groups tribes including here
uh in the western hemisphere where
democracy was the
form of government that was accepted in
all sorts of different ways sort of more
or less direct democracy more or less
republican versions etc
um and then you know the athenians
really sort of theorized it in a special
way and of course rome
helped really establish the republican
way of doing things
but then we do know that in europe
anyway democracy kind of faded away
for a while and so one interesting
question is what was the
original democracy and david makes the
good point to us long before
athens the other interesting point is
how did it come back
into vogue because today if you're a
modern grown-up nation-state you want to
be thought of as a democracy whether or
not you are
how did that happen and again we tend to
look at europe and the
rise of democracy back the recovery of
democracy if you want to put it that way
in europe but then that raises a
question why
was it in europe rather than anywhere
else and so if you look at the world
a thousand years ago and you look at
sort of the major power
centers you would have picked out the
islamic world and you would have picked
out china
maybe india but europe would not have
been in the top two
europe was a relatively weak um
low-income
low-grossed domestic product kind of
place
and so david makes the argument that
interestingly
one of the reasons why democracy sort of
re-flourished in europe
is exactly because of its backwardness
because
the states that existed in europe were
less
good at controlling their populace the
rulers had
less information about what was going on
therefore they could tax them less
efficiently
the bureaucracy was not as good and
therefore they could punish and control
and raise armies less efficiently than
in china
or the islamic world and so in some
sense
democracy had a chance of coming back in
europe just because it was
fighting against a less powerful
autocratic
scheme overall so it's an interesting
take i think
there's of course also a give and take
between science
and philosophy as well as the politics
of democracy that is very interesting to
think about
and of course there's no guarantee that
democracy stays right
it came for a while it went away came
again went away maybe who knows this is
what we have to keep an eye out for
there's nothing inevitable about
democracy and therefore
it is crucially important i think if we
want democracy to survive as long as
possible
to understand the history of what made
it come
what made it go how to keep it around so
let's go
[Music]
so
david de savage welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you very much for having
me
now you've written a book about the
history of democracy and
we've all been taught a version of the
history of democracy
namely that the greeks invented it and
then the romans borrowed it but it kind
of collapsed
and over a thousand years later the
europeans rediscovered it and now we're
spreading it to the whole world
so is that not the correct story yeah i
don't think that's actually the correct
story it's
it's a it's a it's a nice story but it
it misses a lot of things
and i i think that the the traditional
story of democracy as you just summed it
up well
uh it resembles the idea that democracy
was sort of invented at one place in one
time
and democracy is like a torch that that
gets passed on from one society to
another
and there's always some core fragility
to it and if the torch ever goes out
then we're done for and so
that describes exactly the the what you
would have
generally learned or at least what i
learned in school with regard to
the practice being invented by the
greeks passed on
via the romans via italian city-states
maybe thinking about
events like magna carta in england on
eventually some more modern type of
democracy
and what i tried to argue in in the book
is not that the the contribution of the
greeks was irrelevant that would be
silly to say but in fact what the greeks
did is they gave us the word the best
word to describe democracy democracy
which simply means that the people have
power
but they didn't invent the practice
because there were a lot of human
societies
independently over the millennia that
had systems of governance where the
people had power
well that's right councils via
assemblies yeah i mean and that's the
one of the fascinating things one of the
very
fascinating things in your book is this
idea that democracy was kind of
all over the place in one form or the
other in
what you label early democracy it's not
exactly what we have now
but you try to make the case that the
idea of the people having some voice and
how the
society they were in was governed was
not at all a rare precious gem early on
i i think that's right and then the key
element to
distinguish early democracy from the
type of democracy we think of today is
that
if you asked just about anyone today
maybe not just about anyone if you ask
many people today
what is democracy they would say well
democracy is about elections free and
fair elections with
uh multiple political parties competing
and we're hopefully also
it's possible for incumbents to lose
income is just always don't gain the
upper hand
and that that very well describes
elements core our core elements of
modern democracy
but that's not the only way that the
people can have power there are a great
number of human societies
where rulers were not elected they may
have been chosen through some consensual
procedure they may have
even inherited their position but they
were constrained to rule together with
the people in councils and assemblies
because they had really didn't have any
other means of governing
so that's what i would call the early
democracies yeah i mean maybe uh we can
put some flesh on those bones with some
examples because they are quite
variegated and i won't even
suggest what are your favorite examples
of early democracy
well i think my favorite example is is
driven a bit by the
the the ethnographic evidence because
the huron
or they called themselves the wendats
were uh an iroquoian speaking
tribe in what is today present-day
ontario
uh and we know an awful lot about their
entire society and how they govern
themselves because
in the middle of the 17th century the
french crown
sent jesuits out to try to convert these
people obviously that was the the main
goal
but being good jesuits they also wanted
to learn about these societies in order
to achieve that ultimate goal of
conversion
and so they sent home something like 72
volumes of reports from this area
and in there we can find many
discussions of how the the huron
actually govern themselves quite a
sophisticated way
uh involving council governance at the
level of individual villages
and then at each tribe and then would be
a confederation above the tribal level
and it was one where uh the formal role
of uh women in politics was not that
great but it was certainly greater than
it was at your in europe at the time
via informal means so that's one of my
favorites and so
were these councils literally voted on
by
um i mean i guess not white uh free
males but whatever whoever the voters
were there was some
was there literally like a category of
voters and they voted for the council
and the council made decisions
it would be it would make decisions and
it would make decisions in a very
consensual way and it would make
decisions in a consensual way because
one of the characteristics of huron
democracy
that was true of a lot of early
democracies was that um
it is a principle i call the take your
marbles and go home principle that
anyone who wasn't happy with a decision
could always just take off if an
individual tribe did not want to
participate in something the
confederation was doing they could say
we're just not going to do it
yeah if an individual village didn't
want to just uh participate in something
that the tribe was
was uh deciding upon they could make
that they could do that as well and so
that system uh meant you really had to
have a consensus of some sort to be able
to do anything and
was this widespread in the americas at
this time similar systems or do we just
not know
it was very widespread in the in the
americas it was certainly widespread
among the the iroquois who called
themselves
which means people of the longhouse we
have hints of it in a lot of other
societies as well although it wasn't
universal among native
american societies pre-conquest there
was a group of societies in the
southeastern
united states that are referred to as
the mississippian societies that existed
at an earlier phase of of development
and that they were actually more
autocratic in form
okay and also um elsewhere and you know
where else in the world do we have these
early democracies well they were common
in a lot of in a lot of different places
so one of the
core areas where we have some good
evidence comes from pre-colonial africa
uh from uh what is today the democratic
republic of the congo
where people have done remarkable work
uh there was a historian who died a few
years back named jan vancina
who reconstructed a lot of practices of
these societies based on
contemporary evidence as well as oral
tradition so it's clear that
pre-colonial africa is a place where
early democracy was widespread
it was also widespread in some earlier
locales that we wouldn't necessarily
think of like ancient mesopotamia
ancient mesopotamia we think of as
having been governed by
top-down autocrats like hammurabi of
babylon
but in mesopotamia actually there was a
bit of an alternation
over time between forms of governance
that were more autocratic
and forms of governance that were more
democratic and i guess
this makes sense i mean people like to
govern themselves rather than be
governed maybe
um but can we say anything about
how natural or or you know common this
was
overall when a society evolves from just
a small group of hunter-gatherers or
whatever to a more
organized civilization uh is it
50-50 or is it the other rare exception
that things go in a democratic direction
i think we can say that it's natural uh
in the sense
that this was sufficiently widespread
to indicate that it's not a tremendously
rare event the fact that it
occurred at very different time periods
um
in very different places also so it's
not like the practice was just invented
in a couple places and diffused
elsewhere
so so it seems to so that's that's an
obvious indication
if you want to get to the actual
prediction of how frequent it was or not
well
then we could refer to some of the the
data collected by
anthropologists led by george peter
murdock back in the in the 60s and the
70s where they put together a
data set known as a standard
cross-cultural sample
and there you could get an indication
that early democracy was present maybe
in about half
of the 186 societies they considered so
so one out of two maybe based on that
that's very interesting that it's
exactly a hat well not exactly but you
know
near enough to a half close enough close
enough and i think you could
try to define it different ways and that
data has all sorts of
of issues with it not the fault of the
authors but just the fact that it's
difficult to
decide what is a democracy and what is
not a democracy but it was very
prevalent
do we know much uh from the jesuits or
anywhere else about
what we would now call the political
philosophy of these groups i mean
how explicit were they in saying you
know people have rights to be
represented in their government
they tended not it that there's much
less evidence of that
and one always wonders is that a because
europeans were just
uh unique or exceptional in developing a
much more
elaborate and formalized system of
rights
or was it just that when we we don't
have the evidence for this and people
were also
a lot of the the early ethnographic work
that was done was by
um people who didn't necessarily have
very um
shall we say enlightened views of
indigenous peoples
and they may have been less interested
in that but so there are there are
discussions there are senses of what
what uh what the uh
what is um the what is the way to do
things uh certainly in what we know
coming back to the the huron and the
iroquois uh one thing the jesuits did
remark on is that there are very clear
ways of behaving and talking
and making arguments in a council or in
an assembly that there be
these speakers would adopt a different
tone very sort of intricate things that
we might not think of ourselves
but that i think gets a little bit
towards what you're what you're speaking
of
so just as you know people in the u.s
senator house representatives or the or
parliament or something like that
have formal ways of addressing each
other and so forth that was already
there
in the huron assemblies yeah it's very
clear that there there was a way to make
an
argument and it wasn't just shouting
yeah uh or something like that and there
were formalized they're not
well they would be into the extent that
the if you look at the us
house of representatives in the senate
the ways in which arguments have been
made from the floor have evolved
tremendously over time
uh and at any one given time there tend
to be
informal norms about this is the the
best or most convincing way to
make an argument and this is not and i
think the same was true for the the
huron or for their
their neighbors to the south the
iroquois you mentioned mesopotamia as
something that kind of went back and
forth i mean i
guess i wouldn't be surprised if that
was pretty common that there was a
a constant give and take between some
people wanted to be
autocrats and other people wanted a more
democratic rule do we have a lot of
evidence about regime change or system
of government change in these early
democracies
yes we do and mesopotapia is a great
example because there was so much
regime change in that uh early democracy
was a form of government that didn't
have to happen only in person
but it was often occurring in a
face-to-face setting
right and so that would be a
face-to-face setting where the
autonomous community
or a city perhaps would have a council
who would be charged with governing with
with the with governance affairs
and early democracy would be sustained
at that level but then what would happen
is that eventually someone else would
try to say i'm going to try to conquer
several cities
and make myself a kingdom or even an
empire if you want to call it that
and then when these societies when the
form of governance increased in scale
that tended to veer things towards
autocracy right and away from democracy
it's important to take time to do things
that lift us up that make us feel better
one of the best ways i know to do that
is learning with the great courses plus
the great courses plus is a streaming
service and an app
that gives you access to thousands of
videos video lecture courses covering
hundreds of topics
from credible sources from professors
who know what they're talking about and
also from me
and the number of courses is amazing you
can study things like mindfulness and
how to manage stress or deal with
anxiety
to make your own pasta from a chef at
the culinary institute of america
if you want to dig into some of the
physics topics we talk about here on
mindscape and one the mathematical
background
there's a course by robert devaney on
mastering differential equations the
visual method
just to mention one so start your
journey with the great courses plus
today your future self will thank you
sign up with our special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com
mindscape when you go there you get a
free 14-day trial with
unlimited access so go right now that's
t-h-e
great courses p-l-u-s dot com slash
mindscape
and i get the impression from your book
that early democracy was
i don't know exactly how to put it more
of a full-time job than we have now you
know it was uh
there's a lot more direct influence on
the people who are voting on the actual
decisions the government made
i think that's right if you were if you
had the right to participate
then you were participating frequently
and certainly if we go
to the athenian example and when we
shouldn't forget them of course that
this has been traced out by people the
actual number of person hours required
to govern athens was rather
extraordinary compared to what we might
think of today where we're used to
voting every couple years and for most
people
in the u.s or other modern democracies
that's that's the extent of your
political participation
but on the other hand they didn't have
email or social media so they probably
had a lot of free time to devote to
governing the palace at the time
right imagine that and maybe it may be
yeah yeah yeah
a little bit so about athens i mean was
there something special about it or is
it just that that's where our
history sort of focuses back on do they
they
actually innovate when it comes to
democracy i think there were
there were there was an innovation in
terms of the the
first of all the terms they gave us of
democracy itself which
uh and the the principles uh the equal
laws for
all it was innovative in terms of the
breadth
of participation uh in a lot of early
democracies there would have been
wide scale participation but there
wasn't the same principle we have today
of every adult should be able to
uh of course when we say that we when we
say that with broad participation in
athens we mean for
first of all for males because athenian
women were
notoriously excluded from any political
role
really and of course there was a
significant uh slave population in
athens as well
do any of these early democracies
feature
widespread participation by women
well yeah i think some of some of the
native american societies come come
closest to that from from what we've
seen
um i wouldn't say they're the only
example but there there were some there
were
uh some other early democrats of early
democratic uh rule
um around the uh the north northern
parts of the black sea where
it's a very interesting story actually
uh we know from herodotus about the
amazon supposedly and for a long time
people
thought that the amazons were a myth but
then archaeologists in recent decades
have actually
started digging up uh these skeletons
that are female skeletons would actually
see
from their bowed legs or other things
that they would have been in battle
and there are myths about those
societies having having a female rule
um i don't have a record from jesuits at
the time because they went around yet of
having gone and seen these councils but
it's quite likely that they might have
existed
i'm gonna betray my incredible um
ignorance about indigenous civilizations
in the americas but
do we have any written records from them
about how they organize things in their
own words
well we have written we yeah we
so the all writing
originated from three sources from
cuneiform in sumeria
from china with with uh
scrapings basically on oracle bones that
became chinese characters and then with
the olmecs who were a society
in um uh two millennia ago in
mesoamerica
and it is thought that that was the
reason why some societies later in
mesoamerica
had a form of writing so the aztecs
uh had uh forms of writing other
societies between the old mix and the
aztecs uh
do what we don't have because a lot of
this stuff was destroyed
at the time of the the conquest and
unfortunately cortes was not as
interested in the jesuits in
learning about these and writing about
them
um from the inca to the south we have an
even more fascinating example they
didn't have writing but they had this
thing called the kipu which basically
looks
to us today just like a a group of
strings
uh and of different colors and different
lengths but we don't know how to
interpret those now of course the
the aztecs and the inca where autocratic
society is not democratic but
it would have been interesting if we
could know more about what these what
these societies thought of themselves
that's correct
yeah yeah i mean it just seems like i'm
just dwelling on this tremendous
historical tragedy that so much of that
knowledge
was lost um but i guess that's not
exactly news to the to
the world no and you know the other
place where you can see some of this is
if you go
uh to as i talk about in the book to
thinking about
governance in pre-islamic arabia then we
actually
have uh clear evidence uh from early
parts that
that wound up in the koran about and
this thing called the constitution of
medina about a relatively
non-hierarchical form of governance in
localities and we also can
gain inference on that by looking at how
bedouin groups
in the middle east even today govern
themselves and they govern themselves in
a very consensual non-hierarchical way
so that's that's another way to get some
angles so you can actually those are
people you can actually go and you can
talk to and i say
i didn't go and talk to them myself but
i slighted some of them in the book and
it's quite interesting
and we mentioned athens and i did a
podcast quite a while ago with edward
watts about the fall of the roman
republic
and i didn't know much about the roman
republic i knew a little bit about the
empire but
did we give rome any credit for
innovation here in in the sense that it
was less direct democracy
more of a republican system was that you
know an intellectual
change or was it just they kind of
stumbled upon it
yeah certainly we have to give them
credit in two ways one was that they
they were the romans conquered a lot of
peoples and they therefore spread greek
culture
and ideas in a lot of different places
where would it wouldn't have otherwise
been exposed to it
uh throughout throughout europe and
throughout throughout north africa as
well but it's also true that the romans
didn't innovate in terms of the way they
thought about
how a republic should be governed and
they did have a republic for some time
and so there's always been this question
among people who think about
that your subsequent european
developments in the medieval area
they'd like to know well where do these
where these practices come from when we
start seeing
city-states and people in places like
florence and bologna that
govern themselves without without kings
and
uh might say had at times somewhat
democratic ways of
ruling themselves and there's a debate
about whether it comes from the greeks
or the romans or from some uh entirely
different source
i mean yeah you say that it they had it
for a while they had it for 500 years
which is longer than we've had it right
you know that's no that's that's pretty
good and that's right because so far the
american republic has lasted a long
about as long as democracy lasted in
athens so that's that's that's that's
that that's indeed a pretty impressive
thing you're right
there is a time scale there yeah and i
also had the impression but maybe
yours is much more informed than mine
that there were absolutely senses in
which the romans were better at
democracy
than the athenians were i mean the
athenian democracy was a little bit
uh too unstable because you know
everyone could in the
in the city could just change their mind
and call back the fleet at any time
rather than the romans you know picked
some representatives to make choices for
them
no i think that's right and so it was it
was a more
hierarchical form that provided some
stability but it wasn't
a strict and pure hierarchy and so it
was in a more it was a more elaborate
you got this idea
was not an it was not a it was not a
roman idea originally but the idea of
quote a mixed constitution
yeah a constitution having something
that would involve
both the degree of uh aristocratic
influence and a degree of popular
influence and
this was something that was a term that
existed in the greek world but the
romans probably you can think of as
establishing that mixed constitution and
maintaining it for a long time and
the idea of a mixed constitution was of
course incredibly influential for
subsequent right developments involving
the u.s founding fathers and thinking
about how we could
should structure our own republic okay
so if um
democracy was there half the time uh the
other half time there was something else
and
i i guess autocracy is is the good uh
thing to say that it when you're not
democracy or autocracy is that the other
category we should use
yeah you could say autocrat or
authoritarian but authoritarian sounds
like
tends to have a much more 20th century
ring to it um i
i use the for back a lack of a better
term autocracy in the book because
uh it describes the opposite but in his
sense autocracy itself is a misnomer
because of course autocrats don't truly
govern
on their own uh in almost anything apart
from the smallest scale society and
autocrat would need subordinates to
govern through and so it's a
autocratic flash bureaucratic order i
would say well that's i think it's a
crucially important thing right i mean
the strongest centralized dictator
relies
on the support of a very large number of
people right
at the very least they're you know their
military or their strong men or whatever
it's not
no one person can do it all by
themselves precisely and this
is the the way that would be autocrats
got a leg up on thing
if we come back on things if we come
back to the mesopotamian example where
someone like hammurabi
is trying to conquer uh several
neighboring city-states or
or king existing kingdoms then it helps
a lot if you have a standing army
that you're paying and you'd get to tell
what to do it helps a lot if you have
bureaucrats
uh that can help you go out and collect
taxes and assess how much people can
can pay in taxes in the first place and
so all of those aspects that we think of
as
just natural today didn't always exist
early democracy existed in lieu of a
state bureaucracy
you needed the people to help you rule
whereas
autocracy in these early phases was
ruling not with the people but
through your own subordinates who you
had chosen and remunerated
do you think that when autocracy did
come about
it generally replaced some primitive
democracy or are there societies that
were just autocratic the whole way down
it's hard to think that it was that it
was present
from the very very very beginning that
the chinese case is the one where we
have the most
continuous historical record
of autocracy being the the the paramount
apart from it
a couple very very small periods where
china was disintegrating and
there are senses or whether assemblies
and cities that were important
um but really you know from sort of like
the the beginning middle
of the second millennium bc uh we have
we have autocracy and it would be
it would be fascinating to know what
existed before that but before that
we're we're beyond
um the um knowledge of any existing
dynasties and we
and we don't have any written records as
well so you're just forced to rely
purely on archaeological evidence
well we should probably talk about the
chinese example in some detail i mean
um you mentioned bureaucracy a lot i'm
surprised how much the word bureaucracy
comes up
in the book but in retrospect it makes
perfect sense and in some sense
no one is better at the democrat at
bureaucracy
than the chinese system yeah that's
right i think it
it's very interesting if you if you're
someone like me who who started a career
in political science
in the late 1980s then at the time the
whole idea was
china was maybe a deviant path from the
more normal political
evolution path that the the us and
western europe were on and as they got
richer they would
become more democratic and in fact what
we've seen i think actually if you look
at the history is that
china has has presented this continuous
alternative political model to our own
and it's a very successful
depending how you judge success it's a
very successful one right
by its own standards it's very
successful that's right by by its own
criteria it is very successful and
there has been a continuous tradition of
having it
you know in the first two millennia
before the before the common area you
get this gradual development
and improvement of bureaucratic tools
and also technological tools to make a
bureaucracy function and of course you
also needed writing to make a
bureaucracy
function better that allowed
rulers to to govern in a way that didn't
really seek consent from
from anyone uh who is who is who is
representing the people or not from the
people directly either
uh and so it's just it's it's it's a
fascinating example
yeah so i mean tell us a little bit more
about how democracy came to be in china
i mean there's famously you know
examinations uh that the uh imperial
uh system would hand down to let people
join the bureaucracy it just seems
again to someone who is completely
uneducated in these things that
the existence of a bureaucracy is is
much more deeply ingrained
in the chinese way of looking at the
world than in the european way maybe
they talk about the
celestial bureaucracy right which i
don't think that any western religion's
ever really emphasized
no that's right and there are uh you
know it's a very interesting distinction
there are other things like in in the
middle east the idea of the circle of
justice
which uh was something that the the
islamic conquerors inherited from the
sasanian empire before them
uh and that continued right on until the
middle of the
the uh in 19th century under the
ottomans as a political idea
and in the circle of justice there is a
role for the people there's a role for
the rulers and there is a rule for
role for tax collectors oddly enough
and so for europeans this idea that
the tax collector should be a
fundamental part of the political order
you know people in in in renaissance
europe were not or medieval europe were
not thinking or writing things this way
that was seen more like they were
annoyance um
uh and so you're right that the chinese
the chinese bureaucratic model is a lot
more
ingrained and what's something like the
examination system does is it's almost
like an
in an alternative way of organizing
things rather than having a
representative assembly
um rather than having the people in
localities choose representatives and
then you're sent
and you govern with them you choose who
you're going to have and you choose that
based on performance and ex exam which
ideally
would make you less beholden to
localized interests which could still be
a problem even in an autocracy
i mean you could spin it in a somewhat
meritocratic way right you know we're
going to send the best people and
they're going to rule us
no and that's right and so from the
point of view of a
you know contrast a a
english peasant in the 13th century with
a chinese peasant in the 13th century
well in england you would have been
maybe excited to hear that there was
this new thing called magna carta which
was eventually developing into a
parliament but you as a peasant didn't
really have
much of a say in things individually
yeah uh whereas in
in china perhaps maybe someone was
happier that actually the
choose this per i'm not going to rule
myself and no one's going to ask me what
i want
but maybe at least they're just going to
choose the most the most skillful person
for doing the job and that could leave
me better off was there a chinese
equivalent of the american dream i mean
could
anyone take this exam and join the
bureaucracy
yeah that's that's that's that's the
idea uh there's been
of course the examination system uh it
it's
we talk about it as if it was one
constant thing but of course it lasted
for on a very long time from its
beginning in the tongue dynasty
uh all the way up to its abolition and
the you know right around the turn of
the 20th century
um but yeah at times that was the idea
now of course like a lot of
other examination systems in more recent
countries
uh you observe that people who were um
who had attained the highest rank their
children were also more likely to attain
the highest rank
could be for genetic reasons could be
for
cultural capital or any other mechanism
but you're right at least in principle
there was this idea
it was not something that said like this
is exclusively reserved to
um to some people and not others so it's
more like the american reality than the
american dream
exactly exactly i mean you mentioned
that uh actually
before i forget um there's a slight
deviation but
this system in china one way or the
other has been around for
a very very long time is it is there
some sense in which even modern china
which is nominally
uh communist party rule is sort of
borrowing a lot of the superstructure
from that system oh yes uh yes
absolutely uh there's
there's i i don't want to downplay the
the innovation
of the all the tunnel to the 20th
century and how the the prc is
is is different from from existing or
prior
um zionist imperial dynasties but there
is a lot of
uh there is a lot of continuity so in
the imperial era
from a very early date one of the big
things that the government does to try
to control matters is to have household
registration
and to know where people are what
they're doing and to have people
report on each other if there are
problems and this control
in that way was something that got set
up and then you see that persisting
into the brief republican period and
into the the the system of household
registration today where it's
it seems unlikely that the prc would
have had such an easy time setting up a
system of
household registration if this had not
been
the practice from that was very very
deeply ingrained already
december is a busy month a lot of people
are planning for the holidays
but don't put off planning for the
future such as life insurance
if you want life insurance but don't
want to deal with the hassle or expense
try policy genius policy genius combines
a cutting-edge insurance marketplace
with help from licensed experts
to save you time and money right now you
could save
50 or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance
first head to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find the best price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as a dollar a day
you might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape
and the best part is that they work for
you not the insurance company
if you hit any speed bumps during the
process they will take care of
everything
so if you have loved ones who depend on
your income don't go into 2021 without
life insurance
go to policygenius.com and get started
you could save 50
or more by comparing quotes and start
the new year with one less thing to
worry
about policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
well you mentioned the idea which you
think is a wrong idea that china is
somehow an
outlier and uh it's it's the aberration
that needs to be explained it's it
you you cast it more as just a very
successful alternative
a different way of doing things and it
reminded me a little bit of when i read
jared diamond's book guns germs and
steel you know he was kind of a
geographic determinist and tried to
explain how
societies developed on the basis of
where they lived and what latitude
things stretched out on but
all of his theories were completely
falsified by china and he
he knew this in some sense and it was it
was very very different and he sort of
tried his best to squeeze it in uh what
is it that made china different i mean
you mentioned the bureaucracy was there
but then
you you have a little bit of uh more
literally down to earth explanation in
terms of the
former soil and so forth yeah so down to
earth and then i i try to steer
a narrow course in the book or maybe
thread the needle is the better metaphor
um between i'd like to emphasize how
geography i think
mattered how the natural environment
mattered but the problem is as soon as
you start to say that then people think
you're a geographic determinist
and i do i don't by any means want to
say that geography determined for all
future points in time uh how a society
organized itself but
it is quite dramatic to see the
distinction between
the european western european pattern of
extensive agriculture where people are
spread out they're moving things are a
lot more uncertain
makes it harder for rulers to rule with
the chinese pattern where the first few
dynasties arose
on this uh plane in in near the yellow
river and
northeast of china today where there was
a certain type of soil
that was very easily farmed even with
easy
with primitive tools and it allowed for
higher yields and a concentration of
people and also a certain
regularity that you can imagine a
bureaucrat bureaucracy would have found
it easier to
to organize and people were not moving
around and they weren't practicing a
type of agriculture where they needed to
move
every 20 or 30 years and so i do think
and we see this in other areas of the
world that type of
agricult that type of system where
humans have that relationship with
the natural environment did lend itself
a little bit tilted the scales
uh in favor of autocracy made it easier
to rule
uh more or less unilaterally over a
large region i think that's right i
think that's right because
life was more predictable and visible
and
uh legible to use this this term that
the political scientist named james
scott has uh
coined and just because some listeners
might want to google it we're talking
about
low soil or soil how do you how do you
pronounce that's right
i i i avoid pronouncing it because
i don't know exactly how to say it but
yeah l-o-e-s-s
it it is a german term and it describes
a
a soil that is is deposited um
by uh it's a deposit that that it is
very fine grained and so subject to
very easy erosion which has always been
a problem but is also very easily farmed
and so
we know that europe's first farmers were
also
also existed on these if a farm this
type of soil
uh but in europe the low soil was
deposited
in a lot more small river valleys uh and
uh in locations that were spread out
there was no one
large low plane of the type that we
that we see in china and the other
example that one has to confront of
a non-democratic rule but in a you know
relatively successful
society overall is the middle east you
know the islamic
nations the caliphates um and and that
there the explanation for autocracy is
maybe a little bit different
but but not incompatible with the
chinese explanation
no that's right it's not incompatible
but it's fascinating because i think it
it
it's different than what a lot of people
think it was due to the nature of the
islamic conquest that we got a shift to
autocracy but it had nothing to do with
islam as a religion itself
uh what happened was when the the arab
armies uh
spread out of arabia one of the first
places they conquer
is uh the sassanid empire that i
referred to earlier
which was located in where present-day
iraq is southern iraq
and this was an area that had a very
fertile soil where there was an
intensive system of agriculture based on
our irrigation and where the sasanian
rulers
over time had built up a very nice
autocratic bureaucratic
system for themselves where they were
taxing people based they knew how much
they could reduce they would
give you a different tax rate depending
on the quality of your soil or what kind
of crops you were growing
and so what that did is it allowed
inheriting a state inherently a
bureaucratic state
allowed the islamic conquerors to shift
over to a more autocratic
form of rule and so there are while
these traditions say that the first few
caliphs were chosen through shura which
is a principle of consensus and
consultation
after a first after um a a brief amount
a period of time
all that goes out the window and we have
a system of inheritance and autocracy
for rule right so basically the you know
the tools were in place for them to
uh quickly moved in autocratic direction
yeah exactly just because they were
lucky to inherit that from someone else
and so what they did is they got rid of
the sasanian rulers but otherwise they
kept the
the rest of the state and it was very
convenient and it was a huge source of
revenue that allowed them to go out and
conquer other territories as well
and not to wildly generalize generalized
we're going to move back to europe in a
second but what about places like india
japan southeast asia are there were they
autocratic democratic somewhere in
between
so so india is interesting and that i i
i don't want to go too much
out on a limb but it's interesting do we
do have these examples from ancient
india uh that i talk about in chapter
two of the book about uh
examples of ancient indian republics the
evidence is
is not terrific it's not as detailed as
what we have for the huron but it's it's
extensive enough to suggest that yes
there were actually republics that
existed in india at that time now i
don't want to suggest that because india
had
um republics in the time of buddha that
it's necessarily a democracy today
but but that would probably be a little
bit of a
of a leap um but it's interesting to see
that all the same
there was never a period where uh
autocratic bureaucratic rules succeeded
in uniting
all of india in a very very durable way
right uh
and i think that that does matter for
the political trajectory there was some
democratic energy there
somewhere even if only in pockets yes
yes when you compare it to the chinese
case i think
the the difference is really stark okay
and so now uh
with all of that wonderful now that we
know the complete history of early
democracy thank you very much
that was quick but very useful um
but now it gets into the part which i
really think is
fascinating and difficult to grapple
with which is the the implication that
in some sense
what made democracy fail was the places
where
government was effective uh in other
words
whether the technology and the societal
structures
uh were able to give the governments the
power to do what they wanted and you
know you didn't need democracy in those
cases or democracy
couldn't evolve in some sense um is that
is that a roughly good lesson to draw
yeah i think that's that's one of the
lessons that i've drawn myself and that
i'm
trying to convince others of but it's
it's we have a tendency to think of
based on the world that we've had until
recently well if you go back to several
decades where we still used to talk
about quote the advanced industrialized
democracies yeah we're no longer so
advanced nor
so democratic uh but thinking that
whatever generated democracy and
whatever generated progress
must have gone hand in hand the sort of
all good things go together
approach and uh what we actually see is
that
europeans if you if you're if you're in
favor of democracy which i am then you
have to believe
based on the evidence that our
democratic inheritance from europe
is due in large part or at least in
significant part to the fact that europe
was behind
technologically in a lot of different
ways in terms of building states and
that people tend to
not realize that strong state
bureaucracies in europe are a 19th and
20th century phenomenon whereas in other
parts of the globe
they existed at a much earlier date and
that's a
that that was the mind-blowing radical
claim that i got from your book exactly
uh that that somehow i mean in
retrospect it's clear
you know um 1500 years ago uh
maybe arguably 2 000 years ago china was
ahead
of europe um technologically and
a thousand years ago the uh middle east
certainly was ahead
um but and and we like you say we
we like to give some credit to
technology and and democracy going hand
in hand but we kind of get the opposite
lesson here
yeah that's right and uh so now i don't
want to suggest by that
that all new technology is bad and that
we need to
flee from it uh but you can think then
about different types of technologies
and
how technology what types of
technologies gave access to the state
and bureaucracy and which types of
technologies gave access to ordinary
people and so
if you think of writing as being a
fundamental technology for human society
then
there are different forms of writing
some forms of writing pre-alphabetic
forms of writing or non-alphabetic forms
of writing are much more complicated to
learn
uh if you go back to ancient sumeria
cuneiform was something that would have
been learned only by a state elite
or linear b and a in in greece uh during
the bronze age same deal
but if you get the alphabetic forms of
writing then that's a technology that
provides much more
much broader access to anyone who can
learn it so
we could say at the end technology has
had this effect but then if you wanted
to push further
and i touched on this very slightly in
in in chapter four but could take it
further to suggest that then what you
need to be discussing is what
when is it the technology is developing
but it provides broad access to people
in society and where is it technology
that is specially reinforcing
the power of the state bureaucracy but
the other thing that has great resonance
with our current situation
is that one of the things you can do
with technology is
surveillance or you know understanding
what's going on
in your country and that that if you can
surveil and you know what's going on
you can take uh you can collect taxes
and that could make your government
stronger
no exactly and so the the surveillance
capacity of a modern state is absolutely
extraordinary and
would have made any any ancient autocrat
who had surveillance technology
for knowing what people could grow or
how much they should be taxed would have
loved modern
modern state surveillance in that way uh
and of course some
some governments around the globe are
are really going in
in that direction um you have these
wonderful
graphs uh that display very vividly in
the book that
where tax collection was good autocracy
followed
yeah no that's right that's right and so
well the two went the two went hand in
hand that that the autocrats were much
more
had much higher levels of revenue per
per
size of the economy uh and it's really
the differences are really extraordinary
that's right
so is it is it too crazy to say
something like or too simplistic to say
something like the following that uh
there was more or less advanced
technology and social structure
in china and uh the middle east that
enabled autocratic governments to stay
in power and
and you know stave off any democratic
impulses whereas
in europe where the technology was not
as good uh
local sets of people could demand their
rights and become
more democratic but then what i want to
say is
you know there was at some point a
sympathy
between the democratic impulse and the
scientific impulse right i mean
letting people come up with crazy ideas
and explore them
and falsify them and so forth seems to
be a common
philosophical attitude that that is both
in democracy
and in science no i think that's
absolutely right
and and that that gets into a very that
gets into a very big debate
um that was inspired some people refer
to it as the needham question from
the the great china scholar joseph
needham about why
if china was is was developed all these
techniques and technologies
earlier far earlier than europeans did
why is it that eventually
uh europe ended up being the first to
industrialize in the first
modern scientific society right so
what what that's that's probably what
you could say
is that by the very nature of democracy
earlier modern being a somewhat more
disorganized and decentralized affair
than autocracy it gave people
the the margin to experiment
and to think about what they would what
they would like to
to to to do on their own um so
you know one person i think it's a
little bit too trite to say it
this way but someone has suggested that
well if galileo had lived in china he
would have been a state bureaucrat
yeah i don't know maybe that's not true
i don't know but maybe i'm just being
tried myself
it was a little bit trite because i
think there were a lot of technological
innovations in the bureaucracy in china
and
you know the chinese bureaucracy was
quite uh amazing in terms of what it
could be
could do but i think there's something
to that there's something to that that
that underlying idea that you raised
well could we put it this way i mean um
people like galileo
and bruno and copernicus and kepler uh
raised uh fuss and the
institutions did try in some sense to
stop them
but failed maybe because because those
institutions were weaker than they would
have been in a
in a very flourishing autocracy well
that's the other thing exactly it's not
just that the
it's a question of what were the
alternatives to do what
the the nature of european society at
its time
uh at the time of i mean we wouldn't
bruno obviously he got burnt at the
stake so
that was that was a that's a fairly
that's an example of power right but
yes there were
the idea that someone like copernicus
could have this have this uh half of
this uh
i don't know if you call it a treaty is
where you're getting more into your area
of
knowledge than me um and he didn't
publish it until after
he died is that correct that's correct
okay but the idea that that would be out
and um he could do that on his own
with no one watching and have it
published even afterwards is pretty
extraordinary
right yeah so um it speaks to this
this point that you emphasize quite a
bit which is the path dependence of how
these things happen that
rather than seeing it as just
progression
from autocratic rule to democracy um
there's a back and forth that is kind of
unpredictable you know like what kind of
technologies and what kind of social
structures
come first uh affect greatly what will
come afterward
yeah there's a there's a back and forth
and there's especially an issue of
sequencing
um that's i guess that's a term that
political scientists used to
love to use so i use it but when i wrote
the first draft of this book some people
thought oh wow this sounds like a real
libertarian take like if we had no
bureaucracy then we'd be more likely to
be democratic
and uh that's probably true right that
but that wouldn't necessarily be that
great a thing because bureaucracies do a
lot of great things for us so
what i emphasize is this sequencing
question if you have an
early democratic tradition and you
develop that for a society that's maybe
on a larger scale than something like a
village or a city
as europeans did then eventually you can
develop a state bureaucracy and it's a
state bureaucracy that is controlled by
representatives of the people and the
ruler uh himself or herself as well
and so you get to a more virtuous
outcome than if you start with
bureaucratic rule as being the first
step
yeah so i mean let's go let's revisit uh
europe when the democracy
began coming back and you attribute a
lot of it
if to oversimplify once again just to
the fact that the rulers were so
weak right i mean there were kings there
were emperors but there was a lot of
local autonomy
and a lot of the energy for democracy
came from there
yeah absolutely i i think someone
said that one way to sum it up in my
book is it followed to understand
democracy follow the money
which again may be a little bit too
trite but it's one way of saying and so
what what happened is that
both europe and china experienced um
commercial revolutions uh at
roughly the same time um and and
around you know in china a little bit
earlier in terms of around the turn of
the first millennium and europe a couple
hundred years after that
um thought perhaps to have been linked
to somehow favorable solar activity
and in china we have a lot of commercial
development cities grow in size but you
already have a state bureaucracy and so
they just say oh this is great we're
going to tax this economic activity
yeah in europe you get the growth of
towns and cities but these are all
autonomous because rulers have no
bureaucracy they have no real central
power
and so now rulers recognize wow these
towns are rich they're growing rich
they're engaging in commerce we like to
go to war with people next door how am i
going to raise money
well i'm going to have to talk to the
towns in the cities but i have no way of
forcing the towns in the cities
to give me something and i have no
bureaucracy to collect it so you're
forced to
go into this more consensual way of
governing where you have an assembly and
you have a representative assembly
or a representative from the town be
part of the assembly and then you have a
bargaining
uh interaction about how much can be
paid in terms of taxes and so that's
that's where that's how it gets rolling
and were the towns themselves democratic
is there a sense in which
democracy sort of starts on the smaller
legit literally smaller scales and then
expands upward
it varied a lot uh it the the general
view from medieval historians is
a sort of stereotypical or archetypal
view is that
a lot of the towns started off um when
they first became autonomous is quite uh
quite uh non-hierarchical and then
gradually over time they got more
hierarchical
as you would get a smaller oligarchy of
people running the town council so it
really depended on what was the breadth
of participation in the town council
there's considerable variation sometimes
it would be just the merchants guild
the richest people in the town sometimes
it would also be members of artisans
guilds as well so
in any case what's interesting about the
cities is
they were not ruled as autocracies we
it's it's
fascinating to think about we have we
don't have a great list of
really memorable names of rulers of
republican autonomous cities in europe
because the individual rulers weren't
that important it was more of a
collective operation
and where in where should we give credit
to the revival
of uh democracy in europe are there are
there specific places that uh are
most notable there well it's especially
if you want to think about the urban
phenomenon it's especially
something that occurs in northern italy
uh in parts of catalonia
and in the low countries especially also
that are really that are really
the first movers in terms of the
representative assembly phenomenon
and where you get new ideas about what
it means to have political
representation
and what the rights and responsibilities
of different groups are
and was it mostly economics uh and sort
of the organization
of trade that made that happen or were
there
you know were they reading um aristotle
once again and got all fired up
yeah i mean there's it's hard to deny
that the the the rediscovery of the
classical tradition
fed into this but it fed into it that
that you know
aristotle wasn't re-translated into into
um latin until about 1260 and that's
about 100 years after a lot of the towns
in
northern italy became autonomous so the
fascinating thing about this
representative phenomenon and the
autonomous city phenomenon
is it started off with ordinary people
basically rebuilding the ship at sea
uh they they needed to figure out a
different way of governing and they
didn't have
some core constitutional or classical
text to rely on to say oh we just do it
like it says in the book
and what i think one of the things i
think to americans that is most
interesting
is or or most surprising i guess is that
we our myth is that we were
ruled by a king and we threw him over we
invented democracy but
uh a lot of this resurgence of democracy
was
much more gradual and negotiated right i
mean
there were kings but they gave up their
power maybe not willingly but because
they were negotiating with some councils
or some nobles or something like that
no that's right it was it was negotiated
and evolved over time and it was very
widespread within europe
uh it wasn't a specifically
anglo-american anglo
and then american phenomenon but england
did play a big role right i mean do you
think that england uh was one of the
first to really
get the democratic ball rolling in in uh
with its most momentum yeah i think so
and if you want to talk about england
now i think
i don't know if it's too early big would
talk about the shift to modern democracy
because that's what's really critical
for
for so the english uh there's this old
phrase from the 19th century that the
english parliament was the mother of all
parliament
and and that is completely incorrect
because we know that
assemblies in parliament they were
called different things in different
places but
uh assemblies like this existed in in
a great many european states around the
in the medieval and early modern eras
what was different about england was a
new type of it was a mother of a new
type of parliament
and there are several ways in which this
was the case the perhaps the most
important was
that in england from the 14th century
middle of the 14th century onwards
representatives could no longer be bound
by mandates given by their
constituencies so
elsewhere in europe it had been and
contin would continue to be the practice
much more frequently for a town to say
okay we are sending
you as a representative to this assembly
and this is what you can agree to and
this is not what you and what you cannot
agree to
and that was it uh and that was
obviously meant as as a way of trying to
prevent representatives but for being um
uh subject to undue royal influence but
as you can imagine it led to a very
cumbersome
means of decision making because if all
you could agree to is that then then how
everybody would have to go back to their
constituencies and come back again and
so on
and iterate uh it made things very
clumsy it was good for liberty
good for early democracy but it was also
very clumsy in
britain for one reason or another and
it's i don't know if we know exactly why
this was the case
the crown succeeds in imposing
from the middle of the 14th century
onwards that's idea that
members must come with full powers this
is a it's an expression
that existed in uh in other uh european
countries as well but it was really
implemented in in england and full
powers meaning that you could no longer
have a mandate from your constituency
and you could not be
you could not say okay i'm can't finish
and decide what i feel about this
proposal until i go back and talk to my
constituency again
and so that made suddenly the british
parliament a much more
decisive type of organization in a way
perhaps also a little bit less
democratic
how does that relate to what it would
have been in the roman republic
um in the roman republic uh to there
were there would not have been
uh mandates as well but there would also
been the roman system is a little
bit different in terms of the extent to
rely the decentralized forms of revenue
collection so
it's a little bit of a diffic difficult
comparison i think the
the better comparison is with the dutch
republic okay
um the dutch republic the dutch republic
is fascinating because
the the the dutch republic is often
called the first modern economy so it
really was the richest society on earth
in the 17th century yet they had this
very pre-modern form of representation
where
mandates continued as a means of uh
binding representatives
right up until the 18th century until
the end of the 18th century and
the dutch just like the iroquois and the
uh huron before them had a what is an
essence a model of political
representation where you could still
take your marbles and go home if you
weren't happy
and so there are these stories where
they were trying to organize and figure
out how we're going to pay for ships to
for naval engagements against england
and and sometimes they just couldn't get
the money because an individual city
would say well sorry i'm not paying this
time
right i mean it seems like uh
even if there's not geographic
determinism here there's an awful lot of
economic determinism that what really
enabled this sort of
devolution of power from the autocrat to
smaller
uh collections of people was that those
people had the money
that's right those people had the money
but also conditional on there not being
a prior bureaucratic order
because if they were then they could
collect taxes and the autocrat would get
all the money
exactly so that's why the chinese
commercial revolution under the song
dynasty did not lead to
uh the the dismantling of the of the
imperial state
uh in fact reinforced it but you're
right in a context where the
the the ruler starts off weak to begin
with the the growth
of of the the the civil society in that
way of their economic power
um leads to a strengthening of democracy
that's because basically for the
fundamental reason that rulers really
started to need their people
yeah i mean i have okay i have a bunch
of like miscellaneous questions you can
tell me where they fit in here
um even before this renaissance of
democracy
in europe the the church played an
enormous role
right in the life of the continent and
is there some sense in which the church
was democratic i mean you vote for the
pope at least the the council of
cardinals college of cardinals votes for
the pope yeah so the the pope actually
suffered the same problem
as did european monarchs and the pope
didn't really have much of a bureaucracy
and had was
okay the pope technically doesn't rule
but uh if we if
you permit the term the pope had to
manage
things uh with a very decentralized
system of different
abbeys and monasteries and chapters and
orders and so on
um and the pope like a lot of other
rulers
sometimes felt like they wanted to get
money and they wanted to get money maybe
for a new crusade or something like that
and so well what they wanted to do that
they didn't have a bureaucracy to just
say okay you must all pay this
the tithe to the extent existed was a
local tax
um so what the the what ends up
happening is from a very early date in
the early 13th century that the papacy
and the church becomes actually
something of an incubator for a lot of
these democratic um
ideas this this latin phrase uh quad on
this tonguet that goes on a little bit
longer that says
basically that which touches all should
be um
discussed and approved by all um comes
by a tacit agreement
between the papacy and various other uh
church bodies
saying okay if we're going to give you
money then we should have a role in
agreeing like should there be a new
crusade
against the albigensians or against
other groups or something like that
right okay but i mean i i was just
thinking more of the
role model aspect i mean uh what was it
always true
that the pope was elected by the
cardinals
yeah no the pope is elected that's right
uh but i don't know that i
i don't know if that really served as
the main the main instigator for because
certainly what you don't find is
when elections for for uh nation states
come in
later on um it's often in places where
people have
anti-clerical attitudes so france for
example people weren't
saying at the time of the french
revolution oh boy well the popes have
been elected forever so why don't we do
it that way here
i guess the pope was elected but it was
supposed to be uh the will of god who
was moving people's hands
and doing it so maybe not a good role
model yeah no
not i mean a great example if you think
about it but for various reasons i don't
think that i don't think people wanted
to go there
and the other kind of sort of
miscellaneous question i didn't want to
forget was
um when we compare china
and and maybe this also works for the
middle east to
europe one of the differences besides
the fact that there were stronger
uh bureaucracies in china in the middle
east uh there's this
uh tower of babel kind of um situation
in europe where
people didn't share a common language
and they were sort of very fractured
and is it too much or too little to say
that that kind of
differentiation between european
cultures provided some energy
also that led to innovation uh and and
led to europe actually sort of
through the force of competition taking
over the world
yes i i think it that that's been an
argument that
has been around for for some time and
there have been a couple
great books on that subject recently
that provided more evidence
phil hoffman's uh why did europeans
conquer the world is excellent at
showing that
europeans may have been may not have
been ahead of other societies in terms
of most economic technologies
but it was interstate competition that
drove
this remarkable progress in terms of
firearms technology
yeah uh in europe during the early and
if you look at the
the rates uh the the the rate of um
annual rates of technology growth in
in firearms based on basically how long
it took uh
an individual musketeer to fire how many
rounds
you get an astounding rate of
technological progress it's sort of more
like what we're used to seeing
in industrial societies and that are
really growing quickly
and certainly not something that you're
used to seeing in a pre-industrial
society
got it okay very good um the
and then back to the sort of the history
of the the democracy coming up
um even if the
these first resurgence of democracy uh
came before we had rediscovered
aristotle
it certainly seems like there was
theorizing about democracy
that flourished in europe around around
this time was is there what is the
chicken
egg effect here was there a lot of
effect of uh
thoughts about the rights of people uh
that fed into people saying okay yes i
suppose we could become democratic or
was it more exposed facto justification
uh so coming back to the medieval and
early modern eras then
i i think i i this is another thing i
try to steer a fine line in the book
between saying on one hand
i i don't believe in i don't think the
evidence is there
to support the view that it's just sort
of these ideas were discovered by
someone or handed down from on high or
rediscovering the classical tradition
that led people to
behave and suddenly say well we'd like
to move towards democracy
um i think there were a lot more
structural features that we just talked
about that led towards that
that development of a more democratic
form of rule in europe but sorry i was
actually thinking more like the
enlightenment more like you know once we
get to lock and hobbs and so forth
yeah certainly what was very crucial
before lock and hops before all that
europeans developed these theories of
political representation
and theories of estate and what that was
uh
and i think those were absolutely
critical to subsequent
democratic development and also critical
for the
the the idea of liberty itself and i
think the idea of liberty itself
is something that could exist first of
all because you weren't in an
autocratic bureaucratic order where if
you wrote about liberty you would have
been
censored or your book wouldn't have been
allowed but then actually of course the
ideas mattered to the extent they had
some traction to the extent that someone
had to
come up with a particularly elegant and
compact and incisive way of expressing
these ideas
yeah i mean i guess it's a natural
thought for us here in the us
because we tell ourselves that the
declaration of independence and the
constitution were heavily
influenced by some of these uh more
philosophical writings at the time
yes i think that's right and at the same
time that they were also trying to solve
a very
practical from their mindset of a set of
questions yeah
and is it does how well does the u.s fit
into
your general framework it seems to fit
in pretty well i mean can we say that
there was no pre-existing bureaucratic
state in the
in the british colonies and therefore it
was relatively easy for democracy to
take hold
yeah i think that's that that's true and
that what happens if you
if you think coming back to the the the
the natural environment
you have a uh a a situation of
tremendous land abundance uh
after european conquest and that is uh
even in native american populations were
actually
um much less there was the there was
lower population density compared to the
population density in mesoamerica
and then of course uh a lot of the
native huge amounts of the neighbor
population were either
exterminated or died off from european
diseases so
what you get then is this through this
horrible sequence of events you get this
area of great land abundance where
british settlers are coming over or
people are trying to attract british
settlers
and things are going relatively well in
the 17th century
in in england in terms of rate wages are
rising for ordinary people
and so in that environment you have
these people you're trying to attract to
come over
the people who are running the colonies
switched over to saying okay you can
have the vote maybe if you're able to
vote about your affairs you'll come over
and also there was a great break on
things as saying that
people could just sort of take off into
the woods and found their new settlement
if they weren't happy with someone who
tried to rule
in an autocratic fashion um and so i
think that was
it was tremendously important this was a
uh to be fair that you
make this point very clearly that not
only um does this functioning
bureaucracy help autocracy but the
ability to vote with your feet and to
get up and leave is a big boon to
democracy
that's right now the distinction being
of course that this was a story of what
was happening for free white males
whereas for
africans who were brought over the story
was the absolute flip
side in terms of they were being brought
over forcibly to try to
solve a problem of land abundance and
labor scarcity but they didn't have the
same
exit options right that an ordinary
british settler would have had
yeah and didn't get the right to vote so
yeah that makes perfect sense
exactly so it's the same feature of land
abundance that
uh it leads to liberty for some and to
slavery for others
right is there any chance that some of
the early settlers
in the americas were influenced in their
thinking by the native american way of
doing things even if
there's terrible stories of you know war
and pestilence but could there have been
some uh philosophical influence there
that has been a huge debate over time
and it's often been a debate where
people have very
strong views and we don't have a
tremendous amount of evidence so
okay what we certainly know is that
there are great many cases where
uh europeans who came over had a
certain respect for some europeans who
came over had a respect for
native american institutions and so
there's always this debate about well
the iroquois confederacy was quite an
amazing example of democracy
did this influence people like ben
franklin who then helps to help helped
influence uh the constitution and
that's there's a huge there's been a
huge debate over that all the time
sort of attempting to show it that yes
this had this influence
that's a difficult it's a difficult task
it was certainly the case though
that these institutions were that the
native americans had were appreciated
and uh coming back to the huron again
the the jesuits said well their their
their confederation council
is like the estates general which was
the representative assembly in france
so so it's not impossible to say that
there was a connection just
to show it to show that it really made
the difference uh uh these ideas
percolating through is is a difficult
task well and i can certainly imagine
that they did have an influence but that
no one mentioned it right that it was
not the way you said it was much more
prestigious to hearken back to uh athens
than to give credit to the iroquois
uh that is also certainly true that
would not have gotten bought you miss
prestige with a lot of people to say
this is
this is what we're modeling this on so
if in england one of the great
innovations was
basically to elect representatives and
then let them make their decisions
rather than to give them explicit
instructions through mandates
um were there extra innovations when we
got to the us and the constitution
well the the the other innovations have
to do with
uh in many senses pushing there's a
distinction between
what happens under the colonies and what
happens under the constitution in the
colonies
at times a lot of the colonial
assemblies particularly in new england
um tended to bring back some earlier
forms of democracy
mandates were sometimes used the
principle that the representative could
be impeached with it
and the frequency of elections was was
very high so you tended to re-elect
people haven't
have a choice to re-elect people every
year in a lot of
instances uh and so that is much
different from
the british example but then what
happens with the constitution is the
constitution sort of sweeps a lot of
those things out so there is no
possibility of mandates
that gets debated actually there was
debated whether
uh in the debates over what would become
the first amendment some people
suggested that freedom to a free
expression might let mean freedom to
express a
view that would constrain your
representative
um and elections become less frequent
uh and and and so there was a shift away
towards a somewhat more distant
view where citizens only were able to
express their views
every few years instead of every year
and in some sense these are moves
slightly away
from the purest form of democracy right
but maybe towards something more
sustainable and stable well that's the
question right because a lot of the
founders certainly what they didn't want
they had this view that
actual more direct democracy would be
this cantankerous thing that wouldn't
uh wouldn't fly and also they tended to
be richer than most people and so they
were probably worried about
uh being expropriated there's a lot of
movement in the 1780s
about people who only own debts who
wanted debts to be canceled
a lot of this fed into debates about the
the constitution
and so whether you want to see it as
sort of um narrow
cynically minded or broad-minded in
terms of stability
the end-out outcome ends up being the
same
that we have a much more distant type of
democracy than we otherwise would have
had
yeah and is that is there is it possible
to measure the extent to which
uh this experiment that happened in the
united states with the constitution
really did influence
thinking back over in europe
uh i think it it it certainly if you if
you come back to thinking about of
course
the big one the french revolution uh and
others then you you start to get
uh movements that resemble
uh or ideas transmitting that resemble
what you saw in the u.s so it's
certainly there's a debate about
mandates and whether they should be
allowed during the french revolution
and the decision is very clear and very
stark that no
a you know a modern republic or
democracy whatever you want to call it
uh representatives should not be bound
by mandates
right okay a longer lecture longer
electoral terms as well or another
feature
and i guess you know we already talked
about the
fraught relationship between uh
democracy and
technology or science that in some sense
good technology
uh enables you to stop democracy from
growing but then once democracy is there
it enables even better
scientific progress what about the
analogous question vis-a-vis
economic development or inequality i
think that there's a
story we would like to tell ourselves
that democracies are engines
of economic success as well is that a
legit claim or
are we just uh telling stories to
ourselves
yeah there is there are legit claims but
that is something that's been debated
over and over and the data
i think may point to uh a
slight a advance for democracies in that
regard but
it's tough to tell because of course
european europe was the cradle of modern
democracy but for a very very long time
it was very backward
economically compared to other world
regions so that would seem to call into
question that
if there is a in a an added benefit of
democracy
uh several people have suggested
something along the lines of what you
already hinted at and i think
this would be how the argument would
have to be made is to say that it's
precisely because
the democratic spirit goes hand in hand
with this
spirit of free inquiry right into
affairs both scientific and other
that if you see that scientific uh
progress
is fundamental to economic progress as
it most certainly is
then then you could make an argument
it's just that's an it's an easier
argument to say than to actually prove
it
um but but uh but it's certainly out
there as an idea
okay so i i i'm gonna skip ahead a
couple hundred years just bring up
bring us up to today um thinking about
the
status of democracy today and i guess
that there's two sides to that
one is there are still plenty of
countries out there that are not
democratic what are the prospects for
them and on the other side
there are countries that are democratic
where democracy is under threat a little
bit i mean i worry
that the lesson of your book is since
a very strong bureaucracy and
knowledgeable surveillance
state uh is a good tool to stave off
democracy
then we're in trouble because that's
everywhere now
yeah that's right and the power of the
modern state is really remarkable uh in
many cases so i think
that comes back to the the idea
that something developments like that
are not necessarily a bad thing for
democracy i hope
if i'm right i hope i'm right if you
have this long democratic tradition and
pattern of governance beforehand
so if you have a country like the u.s if
we continue to
keep ourselves a democracy where if
there's some development in surveillance
technology that could be used to monitor
people and to know what they're doing
that it's possible for ruler and people
people indirectly via their
representatives
to discuss what sort of limits should be
placed on the use of that technology
uh but for autocratic societies you
would think yes this unambiguously
strengthens the power of the
of the of the of the central state well
presumably it enables
uh people who are pro-democracy to sort
of organize and share information in a
different way
uh that that must countervail a little
bit against the ability of the state to
see what we're doing yeah and and the
the literature on that has kind of gone
back and forth when twitter first
came out uh
uh there there was a lot of discussion
about well how people
in protesting in places like ukraine
were using twitter to coordinate
and they could certainly do that but
then what you see afterwards
uh after the with the the the lack of
the lack of effect of the arab spring
and you know turning the middle east
toward on a
on a more democratic trajectory is that
states also learn to use these new tools
very effectively as well
right and so i i think the jury is that
for things like that i think the jury is
out
uh sometimes it must be helpful for
democracy sometimes and we simply
these are very very in the scope of
human history these are extremely recent
developments
so i i think we should be uh yeah we
it's very hard with that little that
that you know that amount of data
and that minimal amount of experience to
sort of predict which way it's going to
go
right we should certainly be
appropriately humble but and i think
that it flows both ways i mean part of
us part of the lesson is
uh if we look at a place like china
there's no inevitability that it's going
to turn into a democracy someday right i
mean given
its history and the strength of its
current state
and its empirical success in squelching
things like the memory of the tiananmen
square
event and so forth it's completely
plausible that it'll just uh
have this kind of autocratic rule in the
foreseeable future
no i think that's absolutely correct and
so the view that would have been
common circa 1989 would have been
either china would not be able to
continue to develop economically unless
it became more democratic
or that as china grew richer people
would demand democracy democracy of a
sort um
we have uh has not come come come has
not
definitely not come to pass yet and so
if
from people were making that argument in
1989 if you told them how rich china
would be
in 2020 yeah and it would still be very
much
an autocracy i think they would have
recognized that they got the argument
wrong
but on the other side i can imagine that
the world is increasingly interconnected
and something that is true now that
would not have been relevant 2000 years
ago
is that people in china cannot help but
know
that there are other countries out there
that are democracies i mean surely that
has
some effect giving them a little bit of
hope maybe i'm
whistling in the dark here yeah it's led
to this interesting fact that since 1945
most everyone has said that they're a
democracy yeah
uh you know north korea democratic
supposedly yeah
uh mao now emphasized the idea of a
people's democracy which he
contrasted with bourgeois liberal
democracy and so
the chinese have their own word for for
for her democracy minju
and they speak of democracy of a
different very very different sort
uh within china as opposed to um as
opposed to liberal democracy elsewhere
and so it's almost like you you no one
no one is running around saying
praising the virtues of autocracy in the
modern world
you've got to claim that you're truly
democratic
and yet we do have um a rise of populism
and related movements how worried are
you
about the stability of democracies in
europe and the us
and the west more generally i i think
it's quite worrisome
i i think the the i i
sort of say the immediate developments
are very worrisome
um but we also need to keep things in
broader perspective so
circa 1900 about 10
of the earth's population was in a
country that could reasonably call the
democracy
today depending upon which measure by
political scientists you adopt
that number is something more like 60
percent
so that's an extraordinary change in an
extraordinary progress for a democracy
in 120 years
uh if the u.s shifted
soon to being an autocracy or an
authoritarian state that's about four
percent of the world's population so the
bigger picture
is uh that the democracy has actually
been doing well and there are places in
africa that are democracies today that a
lot of people
30 years ago thought would not be
democracies today but then of course the
problem is we live in the u.s and we're
worried about our democracy and
we have reason to be worried yeah well
you know and nevertheless i do like to
end
every podcast when possible on an
optimistic note
uh are there any sort of action items
you can suggest for those of us who are
fans of democracy
to uh either you know directly help it
along or at least to think about it
in the most productive way well vote
first of all of course that's the
simplest but that's only one step i i
think one of
uh one of the things that is the the
weak points of modern democracy or can
be the weak point is that people
start to feel very disconnected
disengaged and distrustful of government
yeah and that is a fundamental problem
in the united states today where you
went from a situation where in the 1960s
about three-quarters of people said that
they trusted the government in
washington to do the right thing most of
the time and now only about
20 say that and this has been at 20 both
during the obama and
trump administrations uh and so you need
to think about what the sources of that
distrust are and how people could become
more engaged
uh and and so i do think that the events
um following uh the horrible killing of
george floyd
nonetheless showed a very bright spot
for american democracy in terms of
people
getting involved uh and and protesting
peacefully
uh in all sorts of areas not just uh the
usual
it wasn't just the usual suspect uh um
in the usual places that being people in
a lot of small towns protesting as well
and so
i think rediscovering any form of
political engagement or expression
or debate is is critically important
because you know if democracy means
power to the people if the people aren't
bothered with by you know trying to
to have any influence on things then
your democracy is going to be pretty
unhealthy
i like that as a closing message it
gives us a little bit of responsibility
uh if if power is supposed to be to the
people and we're the people then we have
to do something about it not just wait
for it to happen
yeah i think that ultimately democracy
is us we we tend to
uh particularly in recent decades in the
u.s blame the government or something
like that but
ultimately democracy is us and so if we
don't do something about it then then
it's not gonna it's not gonna work
all right let's uh stop listening to
podcasts let's get out there and do
something about
it david's to savage thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast
thank you
[Music]
you